let me ask you uh about the unholy uh
this was this fun to make the unholy
would you this was me
it was pre-painted you made this before
the pandemic obviously
i made it before and and during um
but i think i think it worked and the
movie turned out really well it's uh
you know sam raimi produced uh and it's
based on a james herbert novel
who was um called it basically the
stephen king of
of uh britain um and i think the movie
is
is really cool and uh i'm thrilled i got
to be a part of i'm really thrilled we
finished the damn thing
yeah we have a clip here from the unholy
is there anything we need to know before
i roll this clip
um i'm not exactly sure what the clip is
but i was told that it's scary
it's scary and it's dark and you're
looking under sheets
so uh okay well then there you go
[Laughter]
you know what for for zoom covid
pandemic lockdown
that's not a bad setup all right let's
take a look i like it
at this clip from the unholy
what
fun
i've seen that i love is that whenever
someone
shows relief in a horror movie you know
the shit's about to hit them
that's exactly right and then it's
coming yeah
hey let me ask you quickly another
friend of mine is mr paul rudd
and i'm told there's a rumor that you
guys
co-own and co-run a candy shop together
is that right
we do co-own it where is this is this in
new york upstate new york it's in
rhinebeck new york so
uh we bought the candy store oh gosh
six seven years ago the owner uh the
previous owner had it for 25 years
kind of suddenly tragically passed away
and he was a friend of ours
um and we didn't want to turn anything
else and so
we we bought it and uh you know every
now and again you can go in and get you
know yourself a hot chocolate with paul
behind the counter
that's what i've heard is that uh that
that rudd's actually there
maybe too much rudd's hanging out at the
candy shop a little bit probably too
much
you can kind of i hate to say never be
too much
paul rudd but there are times when you
think
yeah come on man you know the ant-man
thing is going really well
you know you don't need to put in so
many hours at the candy shop
but yeah you know there's there's a kid
somewhere that
probably should behind the counter you
know bring home the bacon he needs to go
to school
you're taking his hours yeah it's not
right